I gotta congratulate you the expanding
family how's everything going at home
great yeah feeling great no we're a
little bit like a little bit like asleep
in the house but we're doing well yeah
Rose doing well I was doing great
you picked the best names Rocco Jake
third baby Rafa yeah how did you come up
with that you know we just like the name
and I hadn't named one of my children
hadn't given one of my children a Latin
name yet
and so I bet I'd honored you know both
both moms as heritage and so I wanted to
honor my mom's side of the family and
you know rafael nadal had such a great
year and we work at we were constantly
keeping up with him and watching all his
matches so we were like how about Rafa
that goes well with Rocco that was it
Rocco like him being a big brother loves
being a big brother he's terrific big
brother doting loving yep it's wonderful
with him and really gentle with him and
my oldest is great with the both of them
and yeah we couldn't ask for anything
more
et spoke with Bobby Cannavale a at the
Los Angeles premiere of his new animated
film Ferdinand people think they got you
all figured out based on how you look
this movie it's so cool your kids can
watch it what made you want to be a part
of it well that was one of the reasons
the know so it was my favorite book when
I was a kid I have a you know I have a
22 year old they used to read it to him
and I now I have a 22 month old and I
have a four week old we read it every
night before we go to bed and I just
love it I just love the story I always
felt different as a kid and that book
always sort of validated my feeling
different and made me feel like you know
comfortable now it's a little great book
about nonconformity that I love
[Music]